oder denn je geht es doch jetzt um die
Lieferung von Leopard Kampfpanzern die
als schwere Waffen gelten soll oder muss
Deutschland Leopard-Kampfpanzer liefern
oder doch lieber nicht besteht eine
größere Chance auf baldigen Frieden
durch oder ohne die Lieferung von
Leopard Panzern und was sagt die Art des
Kurses zu diesem Thema über unsere
Debattenkultur aus mit diesen Fragen
begrüße ich Sie sehr herzlich bei Unter
den Linden
[Musik]
und ich begrüße sehr herzlich Norbert
Röttgen Mitglied des Deutschen
Bundestages der cdu/csu-fraktion und
Außenpolitiker und ich begrüße sehr
herzlich Professor Wolfgang Merkel
Politikwissenschaftler Herr Professor
Merkel mit ihnen fange ich gerne an in
Deutschland wird wieder oder man muss
sagen immer noch über die Lieferung von
Waffen in die Ukraine diskutiert sie
gehörten zu den Unterzeichnern des
offenen Briefes an die Bundesregierung
die davor gewarnt hat Waffen zu liefern
hat sich die Position nach den
zurückliegenden Wochen und Monaten
insbesondere durch die militärischen
Erfolge die die Ukraine jetzt vorweisen
kann geändert nein sie hat sich nicht
geändert und dafür gibt es Gründe als
eine Art normative Leitlinie meines
Denkens ist nachdem das Putin Regime und
Russland die eine überfallen hat
völkerrechtswidrig kriegsverbrecherisch
wie kann dieser Krieg beendet werden mit
möglichst wenig
Opfern jetzt hat sich aber bei uns im
Lande die Debatte stark verengt es kommt
fast nur noch das militärische oder man
könnte sagen es kommt fast nur noch die
waffenfrage in die Debatte hinein oder
noch kürzer sollen wir schwere schnelle
Panzer mit starker Offensivkraft liefern
oder nicht ich halte das für eine hoch
fahrlässige Verkürzung der Debatte und
ich glaube dass wir nicht nur in der
militärischen Logik das diskutieren
dürfen sondern den politischen wieder
mehr Raum mehr Kreativität widmen müssen
und das führt mich zu diesem Standpunkt
ich würde gerne noch folgendes
hinzufügen
der Krieg schrecklich ohne Frage
ihn zu beenden haben wir zwei
konkurrierende Linien wie ich das sehen
die einen sagen möglichst schnell
möglichst schwere Waffen möglichst hoch
effektive Waffen liefern dann beenden
wir den Krieg schnell und dann haben wir
wenig Opfer die andere Linie und der
rechne ich mich zu je mehr Waffen wir in
diesen Konflikt hinein liefern umso
größer das Risiko ist dass nicht nur wir
sondern vor allen Dingen Putin an der
eskalationsschraube dreht und der Krieg
sich verlängert ich will deutlich sagen
für beide Positionen gibt es empirisch
zunächst keine
strikten Anhaltspunkte das sind
Hypothesen in die Zukunft hinein ich
glaube dass die zweite Hypothese zu der
ich neige wesentlich plausibler ist und
wir müssen neben dem militärischen
endlich wieder nachdenken wie können wir
ein Konzert schaffen dass sich um den
Waffenstillstand kümmern sie haben sich
sie haben sich schon sehr früh für
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
ausgesprochen
zu den Begründungen der Positionen
kommen wir gleich noch ausführlicher sie
haben schon ein bisschen damit
angefangen Professor Merkel
aber auch an Sie die Frage durch die
veränderte Lage hat sich innerhalb der
Diskussion hier was verschoben gibt es
inzwischen noch mehr Menschen die sich
für Waffenlieferungen aussprechen
ja ich glaube das durch diesen diesen
erneut
unerwartet erfolgreiche Gegenoffensive
der Ukraine
hat die Debatte über die Unterstützung
der Ukraine mit Waffen noch mal eine
neue Wendung oder eine neue Dynamik
bekommen
weil ja immer die Frage im Raum stand
und der Zweifel groß war sie haben das
ja auch angedeutet können die das denn
überhaupt schaffen ich habe das Argument
immer für nicht akzeptabel gehalten aber
das war es stand natürlich im Raum ist
das nicht alles
Vergoldung von Menschenleben und mit dem
militärischen Erfolg jetzt der auch eine
politische Veränderung bedeutet dass in
das militärische hat ja immer nur
instrumentellen Charakter
ist jetzt eine neue Dynamik entstanden
die sichtbar macht es ist möglich das
Putin zurückgedrängt wird dass die
Verbrechen die dort begangen werden wo
russische Besatzung ist allein dadurch
gestoppt werden dass die russische
Besatzung nicht mehr da ist und das
durch die militärische Veränderung die
vielleicht sich weiterentwickelt dann
auch die Voraussetzung für politische
Lösungen geschaffen werden denn das ist
der Dezenz der zwischen uns besteht und
der der verdient es wirklich diskutiert
zu werden was um was geht es eigentlich
geht es darum das haben sie gerade
definiert möglichst schnell
zu vermeiden dass
Opfer zu beklagen sind
oder ist das
eigentliche größere Ziel den Krieg aus
Europa zu verbannen dann muss ich
vielleicht auch kämpfen das ist die
eigentliche politische Streitfrage die
etwas zu wenig diskutiert wird manchmal
wird es zur oberflächlich diskutiert
aber das steht dahinter und meine
Überzeugung ist das schrecklichste ist
und wäre
wenn wir jetzt erleben würden dass Krieg
als Mittel der Politik durch Wladimir
Putin im 21 Jahrhundert in Europa wieder
heim wieder
Erfolg hätte dadurch Schule macht und
dadurch der Krieg sich fortsetzt das ist
das Schlimmste und am Ende die meisten
Opfer auf das Inhaltliche kommen wir
gleich noch ein bisschen stärker zu
sprechen ich wollte noch mal einen
Moment Herr Professor Merkel bei unsere
Debattenkultur auch bleiben sie
vertreten mit ihrer Meinung ich würde
mal sagen eine Minderheitenposition auch
wenn teilweise Umfragen fast paripari
waren
sie haben viel Kritik für ihre Position
noch einstecken müssen in den letzten
Monaten
haben dann aber auch gesagt dass unsere
Debattenkultur durchaus kritikwürdig ist
dass man sie kritisieren kann wie
Debatten hier in Deutschland teilweise
geführt werden
es ist aber ja nun mal eine
Mehrheitsmeinung das waren geliefert
werden sind sie in schlechter Demokrat
dass sie die Mehrheitsmeinung nicht hier
nein bitte überhaupt nicht und
letztendlich entscheiden in einer
Demokratie Mehrheiten daran ist
überhaupt nicht zu rütteln aber unsere
Debatten haben sich verhärtet demokratie
braucht Streit demokratie braucht
kontroverse Debatten sonst lohnen sich
die Debatten kaum aber was wir vergessen
dabei ist dass da war auch ein Akt des
verständigens ist ein Akt dem anderen
zuzuhören die Argumente ernst zu nehmen
auch den zwanglosen Zwang des besseren
Argumentes zu akzeptieren aber was wir
jetzt sehen ist das Debatten häufig so
geführt werden nicht nur in der
waffenfrage das haben wir schon in der
Migration gemacht das haben wir in der
Pandemie in der
corona-pandemie gemacht machen wir in
der Klimafrage wir versuchen die andere
Position schon als entweder nicht wahr
oder als unmoralisch
abzuqualifizieren wenn ich sage wir sei
das ist ein immer stärker gewordener
Duktus mit dem wir Debatten führen und
das verhindert Verständigung und nähert
eine der Erwachsenen Krankheiten alle
unsere westlichen Demokratien eine
zunehmende Polarisierung eine zunehmende
Verfestigung von Lagern die Zugbrücken
werden hochgezogen Verständigung wird
kaum mehr möglich sag nur ein Beispiel
wenn sie früh ihren Laptop öffnen und
sie waren in einer der Talkshows und
haben die Position vertreten wie
problematisch man findet oder ich finde
schwere Waffen zu liefern dann öffnen
Sie Ihre Mailbox und dann kommen fast
Standard an wie sehr geehrter Professor
Komma sie erbärmliches Arschloch also
das ist Ausdruck und von den anderen
unterzeichneten wir sind alles andere
als Märtyrer wir wollen einen anderen
Ton in die Debatte bringen aber man hat
noch ganz andere Tonalitäten drin in
dieser Debatte also ich will E-Mail und
vor allen Dingen Twitter nicht als das
Maß der Dinge herstellen aber wir müssen
anders miteinander umgehen anders
miteinander diskutiert würden sie auch
sagen dass Diskussionen verhärteter sind
das Gesellschaft polarisierter ist dass
wir kompromissloser miteinander umgehen
und unnachgiebiger sind also ich
bin gar nicht so sehr unterschiedlicher
Meinung als ein Gewissen allgemeinen
Trend da stelle ich auch fest dass die
Bereitschaft zuzuhören auf Argumente
einzugehen geringer geworden ist und
politische Themen immer stärker zu
Glaubensfragen eben zu Identitätsfragen
werden und über Identität über meine
Identität kann ich ja nicht mit ihnen
groß streiten so sondern ich erwarte
dass sie sich auch dieser richtigen
Identität anschließen das machen wir
beide nicht aber das ist ein gewisser
Trend und da teile ich auch ihre
Auffassung dass das ein Trend ist der in
den westlichen Demokratien zu beobachten
ist den ich für hochproblematisch halte
am exponiertesten in den USA und dann
sieht man die korrosive also die
zersetzende Wirkung dieser sozusagen
Politik als Glaubensfrage als
Kulturkampf das ist ganz schlimm und
schlecht ich teile aber nicht ihre
Auffassung dass das in dieser Frage des
Krieges
Russland in der Ukraine gegen Europa
dass das ein Beispielsfall für diesen
Trend ist ich das sehe ich sogar anders
wenn sie ihr das was ihr überhaupt
Twitter und sonst wo dann am nächsten
Morgen erleben
das ist das ist aus meiner Sicht das ist
das ist Wesentlichen nur das Produkt
einer technischen Veränderung das was
man sich früher nur gedacht hat dass
müllt man jetzt Ihnen persönlich
technisch sozusagen digital an den Kopf
das ist glaube ich das war vorher nur so
das war vorhanden das war noch nicht die
technische Möglichkeit da diese
Beleidigung unmittelbar zu adressieren
das ist das ist eine Veränderung aber
ich glaube nicht dass sie das Diskurs
prägend für die Frage wie gehen wir mit
diesem Krieg um in der Diskussion ich
stelle fest eine neue Ernsthaftigkeit
das ist tief geht das nachgefragt wird
dass zum Beispiel in dieser Frage junge
ExpertInnen
jüngere ExpertInnen zu Wort kommen die
man bislang in den öffentlichen Debatten
gar nicht gehört hat aus den deutschen
Think Tanks bemerkenswert das ist viele
Frauen sind die da jetzt zu Wort kommen
und ich finde eigentlich ist sehr
argumentativ
und nicht das das ist ja ein so das ist
ein existenzielles Thema das kann nicht
ohne wie soll ich mal sagen ja ohne
Leidenschaft stattfinden das wäre kein
gutes Zeichen ich würde an einer anderen
Stelle die Kritik ansetzen die haben sie
in ihrer eingangsbemerkung auch schon
auf erscheinen lassen was ich neben dem
positiven der Ernsthaftigkeit noch nicht
feststelle ist dass unsere allgemeine
Debatte eine strategische Natur
angenommen hat wir sind zu punktuell
also jetzt reden wir über Leopard 2 hin
oder her aber und so früher und vor
Wochen und Monaten haben wir überhaupt
Haubitzen gesprochen und andere Dinge
sind alles aber was ist eigentlich das
Ziel deutscher Politik was wollen wir
eigentlich erreichen was steht hinter
dieser Frage Waffen zu liefern oder
nicht zu liefern was steht hinter der
Frage wenn der Bundeskanzler sagt
die Russland darf nicht gewinnen die
Ukraine
sollen nicht verlieren aber er sagt
nicht den Satz die Ukraine soll gewinnen
was steht an Vorstellung dahinter das
ist eine strategische Vorstellung die
sich glaube ich von meiner unterscheidet
diese Ebene haben wir nicht erreicht was
aber vor allen Dingen und das ist jetzt
ein nicht weil ich Oppositionspolitiker
bin glaube ich daran liegt dass die
Regierung sich weigert auch der
Bundeskanzler in Personen verweigert
eine wirkliche ehrliche klare Begründung
für seine Entscheidungen etwas zu tun
oder etwas nicht zu tun in der Regierung
ist die strategische Dimension dieses
Krieges für die Deutsch für das deutsche
Selbstverständnis in Europa und darüber
hinaus und und und was wir uns für uns
und Europa vorstellen noch nicht
entstanden das empfinde ich als ein
Mangel weil das das Entscheidende ist
worum es geht und wenn Dimension nicht
eröffnet wird dann wird dann ist es auch
ein Akzeptanz und transparenzproblem in
der Demokratie in der Demokratischen
Auseinandersetzung
aber ich würde gerne auch an Sie die
Frage stellen Herr Professor Merkel in
mehr Roetgen sprach von einer
existenziellen Frage bei
Waffenlieferungen Ja oder Nein sehen Sie
das auch so
es ist eine existenzielle Frage für die
Ukraine für die Menschen dort und für
die Souveränität des Staates beide
müssen geschützt werden es ist
existenziell für uns in der Frage wollen
wir in einer Welt leben in der Regel in
der das Recht dominiert oder in einer
Welt in der Macht gewissermaßen die
Zeichen der Politik setzt natürlich bin
ich dafür für ersteres er soll eine Welt
sein in der das Recht regiert und nicht
die Macht nur die Tatsachen sind andere
das ist die große Frage übrigens unserer
Zeit ja das ist aber das spannende
immer stärker ausentwickeltes
Völkerrecht auf der einen Seite der
Westen propagierte sicherlich stärker
als die Diktaturen in russ Land oder
China aber im Bedarfsfalle
biegt der Westen insbesondere die
dominierende Macht des Westen auch das
Völkerrecht und zwar in fundamentalen in
der fundamentalen Frage nämlich im
Gewaltverbot ich will jetzt nicht
ablenken und auf die USA kommen aber der
Irakkrieg wäre klar etwas wo ein Krieg
herbeigelogen worden ist ein
Angriffskrieg aber mein übergreifendes
Argument ist dabei dass
die diese Normen im Völkerrecht ein
eigenartigen Doppelcharakter haben zum
einen sind sie nachvollziehbar
wertehaltig aber zum anderen gelten sie
für Dänemark sie gelten für Schweden und
vielleicht noch für Deutschland sie
gelten nicht für die großen Mächte die
biegen sich diese Welt sozusagen und die
Frage ist dabei noch
müssen wir wovon sollen wir ausgehen von
der Rechtslage von der sonnenslage oder
von der Science Lage wie die Welt
zusammengesetzt ist wir können uns die
Supermächte nicht so schnitzen dass sie
sich verhalten wie Finnland und Dänemark
also wir müssen erst mal von der
Realität ausgehen glaube ich dass es ein
gemeinsamer Ausgangspunkt und dann ist
sogar ein weiterer übereinstimmungspunkt
dass unser Verständnis ist diese
Realität nicht fatalistisch hinzunehmen
sondern wir wollen sie prägen gestalten
etwas Gutes vernünftiges daraus machen
und das ist das Prinzip des Rechts und
da gibt es jetzt wieder
Übereinstimmungen in einem Punkt eine
Differenz wir sind beide für das Prinzip
des selbstverständlich für das Prinzip
des Rechts und die die Frage unserer
Zeit ist der Konflikt soll dieses
Prinzip das das wird übrigens nicht
primär sagen Russland ist ein Beispiel
das
Russland und der Putin ein Beispiel
dafür der sich um dieses Recht nicht
schert aber die die historische Frage
unserer Zeit wird wird in Peking durch
den Ping aufgemacht das ist die
Grundfrage der Zukunft unserer Welt wie
soll sie regiert werden und jetzt gibt
es einen Unterschied bei aller Kritik an
den USA ich halte den Irakkrieg für ein
Verbrechen für die
schwerwiegendste fatalste
außenpolitische Fehlentscheidung der USA
seitdem Vietnamkrieg auf auf
Luke und trug überhaupt begründet
überhaupt keine frei es gibt trotzdem
einen Unterschied
will das Prinzip des Rechts ersetzen
durch das Prinzip der macht
die USA sind für das Prinzip des Rechts
aber die USA haben dies Prinzip immer
wieder verletzt vielleicht andere auch
aber es ist ein Unterschied ob ich das
Prinzip anerkenne und immer wieder
verletze und übrigens dann auch der
öffentlichen Kritik und die Konsequenzen
zugänglich bin oder ob ich prinzipiell
das Prinzip des Rechts ersetzen will
durch das der macht das ist das ist ein
wesentlicher Unterschied darum glaube
ich sind wir an der Stelle
wahrscheinlich auch einer Meinung wenn
ich den ganz großen Diskurs auch noch
mal wieder auf unser Thema ein Stück
weit zurückführen kann Herr Röttgen
ihre Meinung bezüglich der der
Waffenlieferung ist ja eigentlich
wirklich die Mehrheitsmeinung das haben
wir jetzt schon festgestellt wir
erklären Sie sich das denn aber denn
eigentlich sind ja die meisten Menschen
eher friedliebend
das bin ich auch und ich glaube dass
diejenigen die für Waffen sind zu der
Erkenntnis kommen das ist nicht dem
Frieden dient wenn man gegenüber Putin
blauäugig ist das mit Putin kein Frieden
zu vereinbaren ist jedenfalls im Moment
so wie die Dinge sind und das die Chance
auf Frieden
durch die angegriffenen Ukraine erkämpft
werden muss aber ihre so das glaube ich
drückt das ist die der friedensansatz
derjenigen die diese Position die auch
ich habe teilen aber sie bemerken ja
völlig richtig wie fundamental sich
unsere Gesellschaft verändert hat vor
einem Jahr Jahrzehnte hat die Doktrin
gegolten in in Krisengebiete keine
Waffen man stelle sich mal vor vor einem
Jahr hätte irgendeiner gesagt wir
diskutieren wir haben sowieso schon hoch
leistungsfähige Haubitzen geliefert an
die Ukraine damit sie gegen russische
Truppen eingesetzt werden man wäre vor
einem Jahr für verrückt erklärt worden
und das das reflektiert dass durch
diesen Krieg
nach meiner Einschätzung sich die
deutsche Bevölkerung grundlegend
gewandelt hat sie gibt einen neuen
Realismus wir sind aufgewacht dass die
Bequemlichkeit alter Tage das Ignorieren
der Konflikte ein den zentralen haben
wir eben angesprochen dass das nicht
mehr geht und das finde ich sehr
bemerkenswert wie grundlegend die
Bevölkerung einen neuen Realismus
angenommen hat und ihre glaube ich
Mentalität und Sichtweisen verändert hat
ich glaube übrigens dass die Bevölkerung
weiter ist als unsere Regierung in der
Realismus der Lage Einschätzung wenn man
das nochmal bezahlen ein bisschen
unterstützen möchte 52 Prozent der
Deutschen unterstützt eine Lieferung
eine eventuelle Lieferung von Leopard
Panzern und auffällig ist das vor allen
Dingen die Jüngeren unter 40
zustimmen nämlich 68 Prozent der unter
40-Jährigen was sagt das aus
naja es gibt eine
es sagt mindestens zweierlei aus
zunächst der
Reflex den auch ich habe da greift ein
ein Land eine Regime und an der Spitze
dieses Regimes Putin ein anderes Land an
da hat man sofort den Reflex ein
gerechtigkeitsreflex der muss bestraft
werden nicht nur weil die Normen
geschützt werden müssen über die wir
gesprochen haben sondern dieses
Verbrechen gegen das Völkerrecht darf
nicht ungesühnt bleiben dafür gibt es
viele ich glaube wir sind ja nicht beim
Strafen und Süden sondern sind beim
hindern beim
aufwärmentionen es gibt nicht so etwas
wie ein ponitives also straffälliger
Rechte und es gibt nicht die Idee dass
man Staaten Daten bestrafen können aber
es ist ein Gerechtigkeit Reflex den ich
durchaus Teile den ich durchaus Teile es
muss dem angegriffenen geholfen werden
über Nothilfe und wie man das alles
definieren macht es gibt aber noch etwas
anderes es gibt eine eine eine
Sehnsucht nach
einer neuen Wehrhaftigkeit und zwar nach
in der Zwischenzeit die zwischen und
1990 mit dem Kollaps des Sowjet
Imperiums bis sagen wir sozusagen an die
2020er Jahre hinein haben wir zwar
Kriege erlebt aber nicht in dieser Art
und Weise wo wir uns über die Zukunft
der Weltordnung Gedanken machen und das
hat auch tatsächlich mit dem Aufstieg
der Weltmacht China zu tun also es gibt
eine Sehnsucht nach etwas neun und Herr
rückten sie haben vorhin gesagt von den
jungen
Wissenschaftlerinnen in den Think Tanks
Meister war auch regierungsnah oder
zumindest staatsnah was mich dabei
wundert ist zum einen spricht man über
eine feministische Außenpolitik was
immer das genau ist aber die Idee ist
mehr Empathie mehr Verständnis weniger
Gewalt und diese jungen Frauen sind mit
einer vehements sozusagen für die
Waffenlieferungen schlagen eine Allianz
unter deutscher Führung vor die die
Leopards in Europas einsammeln soll
tüchtig machen und liefern also hier
sehen wir tatsächlich eine Zeitenwende
im Denken und ich meine nicht nur
positiv es schleift sich in unseren
Sprachgebrauch ein der Spiegel schreibt
Panzer jetzt die eine panzerwände also
über Sprache über unser Denken und mit
dem Risiko dass wir denken letztendlich
wie eine Supermacht wie die USA die das
militärische immer ganz anders in der
Prioritätenliste der Politik gehabt hat
als wir das gemacht haben oder als es
Frankreich bei Großbritannien ist es
vielleicht noch etwas anders Sehnsucht
nach neuen Schluss mit der
friedensduselei
Problematik da schließen sich zwei
Fragen an einmal Annalena baerbock hat
gestern doch ich glaube ich weiß nicht
ob sie es gesehen haben war Anne Will
das nicht mehr so vehement vorgebracht
tatsächlich Leopard Panzer zu liefern
und die zweite Frage der Kanzler wird ja
oft damit konfrontiert er zögere und
zaudere letztendlich und
verweist dann oft an die EU-Partner oder
auch an die NATO dass man sich mit den
abstimmen müsse
die würden auch keine Panzer westlicher
Bauart liefern was ist daran denn zu
kritisieren letztendlich
also bei der Außenministerin finde ich
ist zu kritisieren dass man das ist gute
Gründe gibt und sie hat sie auch schon
öffentlich geäußert auch ihre Meinung
dass sie zu dieser Meinung nicht steht
dass sie nicht dafür kämpft sondern
eingeknickt ist
dafür ist die Frage zu ernst und auch
von der Außenministerin muss man dann
erwarten dass sie ihre Meinung begründet
und nicht den Koalitionsfrieden
wichtiger findet als den Frieden
das ist meine Kritik gar nicht dass sie
die falsche Meinung hat sondern dass sie
sie nicht vertritt
beim Bundeskanzler ist meine Kritik
dass das was er vorträgt für seine
Position
aus meiner Sicht
es sind Ausreden es ist eine ganze Serie
von Ausreden ich will jetzt nicht es
fing an damit das gesagt wurde das ist
alles geheim da dürfen wir gar nicht
drüber sprechen und es war über Nacht
auf einmal alles publiziert also die
Argumente tragen nicht und sie
widersprechen sich zum Teil und mal
können die Ukraine das nicht bedienen
und mal fehlen die Ersatzteile und der
Kern ist der will es nicht er will es
nicht auch das der deutsche Sonderweg
ich meine wir werden von mir Alliierten
bedrängt zu liefern als dass die Angst
vor einem Sonderweg haben das ist das
ist meine mindestens ja ich würde fast
sagen wichtigere Kritik dass er nicht
offen ehrlich sagt was ist die
Motivation für meine Position ist nicht
zu wollen
sich mit den europäischen Partnern dann
abzustimmen
der Punkt ist dass es dass er sich
dahinter versteckt die die
osteuropäischen und baltischen Partner
zum Beispiel die sind zutiefst
enttäuscht über die deutsche Politik die
wollen das dass wir sind nicht ihrer
Meinung sind meiner Meinung dass das
geliefert wird und die sagen euer
Sonderweg besteht darin dass ihr uns
schon wieder im Stich lasst
das ist übrigens der Sonderweg nach Nord
Stream 2 da haben wir auch gesagt eine
Frage unserer nationalen Sicherheit das
hat euch nicht gekümmert das war in
deutscher Sonderweg jetzt machte wieder
einen deutschen Sonderweg kennen das
Argument das natürlich die USA zum
Beispiel auch keine keine entsprechenden
Panzer liefern ja das Argument wurde
mich dann überzeugen wenn wir auch nur
ungefähr annähernd im übrigen so viel an
Unterstützung militärischer
Unterstützung gemessen an unserer
Wirtschaftskraft leisten würden wie die
USA das tut das beschämende für die
Europäer ist dass die USA alleine mehr
an Unterstützung militärische
Unterstützung an die Ukraine leisten als
alle europäischen Staaten zusammen als
alle europäischen Staaten zusammen das
ist das beschämende und die gemeinsame
Linie kommt ja nicht zustande weil die
deutsche Politik die deutsche Regierung
sagt wir wollen es nicht und für Joe
Biden ist
verständlich richtigerweise das
Wichtigste dass es keinen Ärger gibt
zwischen wichtigsten Alliierten wie die
USA und Deutschland das sind
das heißt der Bundeskanzler sorgt dafür
dass es diese Linie nicht gibt und dann
sagte wir haben aber keine gemeinsame
Linie für die Exporte das ist nicht
ehrlich und in solchen Fragen nicht
offen und ehrlich und transparent zu
kommunizieren ist ein wirkliches
führungsversagen ich halte es dann auch
in der Sache für falsch ich glaube er
hat eine falsche Präferenz für die
künftigen Beziehung zu Russland ich
finde der Frieden in Europa ist das
entscheidende Kriterium und nicht das
andere aber darüber kommt es gar nicht
zum wirklichen Streit weil er die weil
er seine Motivation nicht der
Öffentlichkeit gegenüber darlegt das
finde ich einen schwerer teilen Sie die
Kritik natürlich nicht wir diskutieren
ja auch
da sieht plausibel das könnten Sie sie
teilen ja das stimmt ich finde sie nicht
richtig plausibel erstens hat der
Kanzler deutlich gesagt sie haben ihn
vorhin zitiert die Ukraine darf den Kick
nicht verlieren Russland nicht
da sieht man einen Zwischenton da sieht
man ein Zwischenton und der Zwischenton
der kommt daher weil er ein
eskalationsrisiko fürchtet und das ist
eine
hochlegitime verantwortungs Furcht auch
dem eigenen Land gegenüber und der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung man darf nicht
fahrlässig so seine Argumentation und
die übernehme ich an dieser Stelle nicht
fahrlässig das Risiko eingehen die
nächste Bindung in der
kriegsintensitätsspirale zu drehen ich
rede noch gar nicht über einen denkbaren
oder
[Musik]
ein zu befürchtenden taktischen
Nuklearschlag ich denke an
konventionelle Waffen und da hat
Russland einfach ich habe noch zwei
Sätze da hat Russland einfach noch nicht
seine sein Potenzial
ausgespielt das wissen wir alle
die
gewässermaßen ein Bombardierung der
massivsten Art gegen die Infrastruktur
oder gegen Städte steht alles noch nicht
auf dem Programm aber wenn wir Putin als
betriebsvertreter nicht nur das
Verbrechen Abbildung also einen Krieg zu
beginnen sondern auch in Bello gesehen
haben dann sollten wir ihm das auch
zutrauen und das beunruhigt den Kanzler
mit Recht darüber nachzudenken und nicht
hora schreien alle Waffen in die Ukraine
drückt ja nicht nur den Kanzler sondern
auch Joe Biden hat vor
Kurzschlusshandlungen Putins gewarnt bzw
hat gesagt
geht es mit den nuklearen Waffen
durchaus etwas ist was man im Kopf haben
sollte ich bin auch gegen
Kurzschlusshandlungen und ich bin auch
dagegen etwas fahrlässig zu tun aber ich
würde gerne bei diesem Punkt bleiben den
Sie über es ist ja richtig wichtig dass
man bei diesem Punkt bleibt sie sagen
also jetzt die eskalationsgefahr ist das
Argument meine meine erste
Schlussfolgerung um meine Bitte an den
Bundeskanzler wäre dass er das genauso
klar sagt dass er sagt nicht es gibt
keine gemeinsame Linie sondern meine
Linie ist Panzer nicht zu liefern weil
damit eine unverdrehbare
eskalationsgefahr verbunden ist dann
soll er das so sagen das tut er nicht
das war meine
demokratiekritiker die meine
transparenzkritik und nun in der Sache
das ist das ist ja dann auch ihre
Position und ich glaube uns auch dass es
die kanzlerposition ist
was heißt das
wenn man sich das zu eigen macht wenn
man sich diese Position sozusagen die
Angst vor einer
weiteren Eskalation durch Putins
Russland wenn die Ukraine in die Lage
versetzt wird sich wehren zu können
wenn wir das wenn wir diese Angst als
Richtschnur unserer Politik akzeptieren
denn akzeptieren wir aus unserer Angst
heraus
dass Krieg angewendet wird gegen andere
weil die kriegsverhinderung ja dem
Kriegstreiber ein weiteres Argument gibt
oder sie fürchten das den Krieg noch
auszudehnen wenn wir nicht gegen die
Methode Krieg oder Krieg als Methode der
Politik
bereit sind den angegriffenen zu
verteidigen
dann führen wir diese Methode ein und
darum ist es in fatales es ist eine
fatale Position zu sagen aus unserer
Angst heraus gestatte ich dem Aggressor
dass er sich durchsetzt in dem ich dem
angegriffenen die mögliche Hilfe
verweigere damit bringen sie den Krieg
nach Europa und darüber müsste man
diskutieren dann würden unterschiedliche
Politikansätze sichtbar wie es jetzt in
dem Gespräch wird wird aber nicht auch
in dieser Woche glaube ich im Bundestag
nicht weil es zu dieser offenen
Begründung nicht kommt es gibt ein
zentralen begriffsunterschied ich habe
Verantwortung gesagt und sie sagen Angst
mit der Verantwortung meine ich eine
doppelte der Kanzler hat eine
Verantwortung in erster Linie natürlich
gegenüber seinen eigenen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern aber er hat auch eine
Verantwortung was bezwecken was können
diese Waffen die Deutschland mitliefern
in dem Krieg tatsächlich
produz erklären und da könnte man ja
sagen eine Verlängerung wenn man die
Annahme hat der Krieg wird dadurch
verlängert dann heißt es ab nicht nur
abstrakte er dauert länger sondern das
heißt zehntausende mehr Tote wenn der
ein oder zwei Jahre dauert wenn etwa die
Creme zurückerobert werden solle dann
hat man auch als helfende als
unterstützendes Land die Verpflichtung
darüber nachzudenken dürfen wir das
dürfen wir so viele Tote in Kauf nehmen
um eben nicht über Angst mögliche
weitere Kriege zu produzieren zunächst
ein Begriff Verantwortung Verantwortung
ist kein Kriterium dass wir zu einer
Unterscheidung unserer Positionen oder
auch der Position des Kanzlers machen
sollten ich gestehe ihnen zu wie auf dem
Bundeskanzler dass er aus Verantwortung
handelt ich würde Sie bitten auch mir
zuzugestehen dass mein Denken und mein
meine Funktion aus Verantwortung kommen
das ist gelegentlich geschieht das so
dass der eine Verantwortung für sich
reklamiert und dem anderen das Gegenteil
vorwirft das würde ich uns allen mal
zugestehen dass wir alle verantwortlich
handeln wir haben nur eine
unterschiedliche Folge Einschätzung
einer sozusagen eine Prognose
Einschätzung meine Prognose von Putin
ist dass er dass er es so perzipiert
wahrnimmt wie ich es beschrieben habe
dieser Kanzler und diese Deutschen haben
Angst um sich und darum lassen sie ihre
Nachbarn im Stich und das ermuntert mich
als Putin weiter auf die Stärke zu
setzen und noch mehr Angst zu machen und
ich habe das richtige Instrument gewählt
Putin versteht diese Sprache nicht er
versteht sie als Einladung weiter zu das
ist die unterschiedliche Einschätzung
gerade mit Putin telefoniert an
90-minütiges
Telefonat mit freundlichen Ton ja und es
hätte durchaus Bewegung gegeben weil
glaube ich der zweite Satz dazu lässt
das auf eine diplomatische Lösung
kaufen nein das wäre das ist das ist ein
Teil des Fehlers der darin liegt dass
man diese
Illusion dadurch nähert
es ist man erzeugt dadurch ein
Fehlverständnis eine fehlanalyse
desjenigen was Putin Wladimir Putin
treibt das wissen sie aber genauso wenig
wie der Kanzlerin
haben und meine Einschätzung ist das
Putin die
unerbittliche Ambition und ich würde
auch sagen Obsession hat für Russland
wieder imperiale Macht zu begründen
er dachte dadurch dass er die Ukraine
Russland einverleibt so wie es bienev
präsenski mal gesagt hat ohne ohne die
Ukraine ist Russland ein Land mit der
Ukraine ist ja Imperium das war seine
Fehleinschätzung dass die Ukraine sich
dem widersetzt und so weiter aber das
ist ein Ziel geht ist eigentlich im Plan
B schon nämlich da ich die da Putin die
Ukraine wieder erobern noch
kontrollieren kann steht jetzt
Vernichtung physische Vernichtung der
Ukraine an das ist ein Programm und
dadurch ist er auch nicht durch
Gespräche und durch Argumente des
deutschen Kanzlers abzubringen muss ich
dann umgekehrt Fragen Herr Röttgen
welches Kriegsziel gibt es denn heißt
das dass man wenn sie es so beschreiben
Putin grundsätzlich
vernichtend zerstören muss um ihn zu
stoppen wie heißt denn das Kriegsziel
das aus meiner Sicht
das ist eine schwierige ist eine
schwierige Frage die wir
interessanterweise zum Beispiel in der
Öffentlichkeit des Deutschen Bundestages
ist noch nicht diskutierter auch sehr
seltenen talkschutz
gelegentlich schon und ich glaube als
zielst du definieren ist
sie haben eben auch lateinisch
gesprochen dass wir den Status Quo Ernte
bellum wieder erreichen dass wir also
Putin auf die russische Putins Armee auf
den Stand zurückbringen
wo Russland vor Beginn des Krieges war
also auch vorbesetzung der Krim nein vor
Beginn des Krieges am 24
sondern 2022 genau das aus meiner Sicht
denn wenn das erreicht würde dann wäre
erreicht dass durch den Krieg zwar viel
zerstört aber von durch Putin nichts
gewonnen wäre so würde ich es definieren
und ich würde darum nicht sagen
der völkerrechtmäßige Zustand sollte
wiederhergestellt werden das würde ich
nicht sagen und dann müsste man auch mit
der Ukraine reden die eine
völkerrechtlich perfekt legitime legale
Position vertreten würde wenn sie sagt
doch wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit wir
holen uns das alles zurück ich glaube
dass das da bin ich jedenfalls im Moment
würde ich nicht zu raten und würde auch
nicht sagen das ist dann deutsche
Politik dabei zu unterstützen aber die
Differenzierung könnten wir uns
tatsächlich annähern wenn sie sagen
statt Status Quoten also gewissermaßen
Januar
das sind längst nicht mehr die keksziele
die etwas selensky der Öffentlichkeit
präsentiert er sagt vollständiger Abzug
der Truppen vollständig hier
Wiederherstellung der
territorialen Integrität des Landes die
usa-position ist eine legitime
aber das ist gewissermaßen sein Ziel
legitim
rechtlichen Sinne möglicherweise mit
verheerenden Konsequenzen was Opfer an
betreffen würde die USA und der
Verteidigungsminister der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika hat sein eigenes
Ziel definiert und sagt naja es steckt
aber etwas dahinter die USA haben eine
andere haben durchaus auch
unterschiedliche Interessen zu Europa in
dem Konflikt und die USA sagen möglichst
Russland so weit auf die Knie zwingen
dass er nicht in einer Dekade oder
länger daran denken kann noch einmal
einen solchen Aggressionskrieg zu führen
letzten zwei Sätze dazu wenn das
tatsächlich das Ziel ist hat das im
Hintergrund auch so etwas wie ein
möglichst möglichen regime change also
ein wandelwechsel des Regimes dass wir
uns alle unter Umständen wünschen wir
wünschen uns jetzt nicht wenn wir eine
realistische Analyse von Russland und
ansehen da ist nicht der demokratische
Frühling zu erwarten sondern viel eher
sozusagen dicke tickt die wir heute in
diesen Tagen in Moskau hören eine eine
ein Bündnis von
superimperialisten
Ultranationalisten und vielleicht ein
paar Wetter wo also Altkommunisten das
ist werden noch verheerender als ein
Putin der einigermaßen rational wenn
auch viel handelt an beide müsste ich
jetzt die Schlussfrage stellen weil wir
sind fast schon durch er hat keinen
schwer ich würde würde gerne das was er
mir gesagt Auto Stück weit aufnehmen
wenn das Vertrauen zu Russland und die
internationalen Beziehungen durch das
Kriegsgeschehen und auch durch die
Kriegsverbrechen die wir gesehen haben
nun so zerstört es auf welcher Basis
kann denn überhaupt eine stabile
Friedensordnung stattfinden
kann das nicht im letztendlich nur auf
dem Prinzip der Abschreckung bestehen
also die klare Schlussfolgerung aus
diesem Krieg ist dass es nach dem Krieg
und der Tag wird ja kommen darum gehen
muss in Europa eine sicherheitsordnung
gegen Russland zu etablieren die
übernatte und EU hinausgeht das ist
unabweisbar und wir müssen und dürfen
aber nicht das Ziel aus den Augen und
aus dem Kopf verlieren dass wir
anstreben müssen eine europäische
Friedensordnung das andere ist eine
sicherheitsordnung einer europäische
Friedensordnung mit Russland als
unverzichtbaren Teil aber für die
nächsten Jahre ich weiß zwar nicht wie
die Zeit nach Putin in Russland ausgeht
ich glaube auch dass es nicht
voraussagbar ist aber für die das was
wir erkennen können heißt Sicherheit
gegen Russland
als Gebot der Erfahrung dieses Krieges
auf welcher Basis können wir zu einer
Friedensordnung kommen ich würde sagen
mittelfristig schon und natürlich
langfristig wieder mal eine kleine
Übereinstimmung kann jetzt nur eine
friedensarchitektur geben
mit Russland auf der Basis von durchaus
veritablen abschreckungsmomenten auch
die Ostpolitik von Willy Brandt hat
übrigens diese beiden Säulen gehabt zum
einen militärische Stärke aber dann
Angebote zu Kooperationen
das war aber im Kalten Krieg die Methode
diesen kalten Krieg ein bisschen weniger
kalt zustellen und das war sozusagen ein
verständigungsangebot ich glaube nicht
dass wir ohne letztendlich auf der
Position der Stärke ohne Kooperation mit
Russ das ist für uns wichtiger als alle
osteuropäischen Staaten von der
Sicherheit her für unser Land also wir
brauchen das ist der dramatische
Unterschied also jetzt das ist das muss
noch sein
genau zu dem wie wir gesehen werden
dieser also es war dann fataler Satz
Russland ist Russland der ist für uns
wichtig als all die Osteuropäer
Sicherheitsarchitektur natürlich ist der
spalterische Satz das sieht man im
Baltikum sicherlich anders aber
Polen vor und Deutschland und diese
Regierung ich fürchte wir müssen sie
beide noch als zweites historische
Frauen gemacht genau
Deutschland in Europa wir müssen das
noch mal auflegen um die Diskussion noch
mal 45 Minuten vorzusetzen wir gehen mit
dem letzten Satz ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für die durchaus diverse
Diskussion und bedanke mich bei Ihnen
sehr herzlich fürs zuschauen morgen um
22 Uhr 15 sehen Sie an dieser Stelle die
Phönix Runde und ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen sehr informativen Abend bei
Phoenix
[Musik]